we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i got
another one of these weird voicemails
from someone who seems to believe I'm
specifically avoiding picking up on them
during live calls because I'm afraid for
some reason take a listen to this cluck
cluck chicken little whiting take my
call man I guess you might be a little
bit too scared to take off somebody
doesn't show like your little Jerry
there's bad people with their
homosexuals they want to kill oh yeah
listen I have no clue who you are I
don't think people understand if if
you've called in to the show before and
I've picked up on you we put your name
into our caller ID system we'll put a
note about whether you were a good
caller or not a good caller yes we have
those notes we'll put a note in about
whether you were on some kind of
ridiculous Bluetooth speakerphone
underwater paper crinkling over the
phone connection or whether you had a
good connection and I would know what to
expect if you've never called in before
and been picked up on I have no clue who
you are I see a list of 50 phone numbers
there is no possible way that I would
recognize oh wow that phone number that
phone number clearly is attached to a
very sophisticated and articulate
trumpet who could make me look really
really bad
I shouldn't pick up on him let me go to
someone else it's not how it works my
friend okay you got to come back to
reality we've got a great bonus show
today we will talk about prosecutors
dropping criminal charges against Kevin
Spacey is this another one of these two
justice systems that we talked about one
for the rich and one for everybody else
or was this the right decision or some
combination of the two we will also talk
about Democrats issuing warnings against
the Russia based face morphing app we
will also see producer pat aged he
clearly not heeding the warnings about
the apps information security and we
will also talk about the incoming
massive heat wave it is going to get
really bad here in Boston and many other
parts of the country all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
become a member or a patron to get
instant access to the bonus show and I
will speak to you then